there are a few places in America where
gun violence is a more intractable
problem than the City of Chicago were
just over two months into the year and
according to the most recent data from
the Chicago Tribune's crime team there
have already been 50 homicides that's
actually a small improvement from the
same time last year but over the years
the death toll has been immense between
1990 and 2010 just over 14,000 people
were killed and an estimated 60,000
wounded by gunfire
but while the numbers are shocking they
don't say much about the human toll the
effect on individuals families in
neighborhoods
Alyx Kotlowitz author of the best-seller
there are no children here is trying to
tell those stories in his new book an
American summer love and death in
Chicago and we welcome him him we
welcome you here now Alex well thanks
for having me this book took five years
to write you interviewed over 200 people
it focuses on the summer of 2013 and I
just want to read to you something
violence has a way of exposing cracks in
your universe best not to speak of those
you love how did you get so many people
to talk to you yeah well you know it's
actually it's the real I mean for me
it's the there so there are 14 stories
in the book and it's the one commonality
is I think for many of them it was the
first time that they'd ever talked about
what was for them the most distressing
moment their life and they had lost
somebody there's somebody who taken
somebody's life and I think there's this
kind of tension where on the one hand
they're holding on to all this inner
turmoil and inner pain and yet on the
other hand they want to share and talk
about their experiences because there's
this other sense of loneliness you you
just you describe a social worker who
brings up the term complex loss right
what exactly is in formal terms of
social workers use to talk about the
trauma that people experience from the
violence and you see you know there's
similarities between what they
experienced and what veterans
experienced returning from combat say in
Iraq
Afghanistan because it's a constant
sense of violence well in you know for
the veterans it's you know this cotton
you know the this agitation he used to
anger you know self medication you see
that in people in Chicago but of course
there's nothing post about the
post-traumatic stress because it's just
they lose somebody close to them and
they still are looking over their
shoulder for what lies ahead and there's
no escape you know you know they were
interestingly enough the Chicago Police
Commissioner Eddie Johnson talked about
building community trust as a way to try
to help curb some of the issues of
violence though you've been in this
community is that something that's
realistic
well I think it's realistic I think it's
actually necessary but it is true that
the relationship between the police and
communities of color is really fraught
especially of course in the wake of the
laQuan McDonald shooting which happened
after this summer but one of the stories
I tell in my book is just how awful
police shooting in which there was
really very little accountability and I
think that somehow we've got to recreate
that trust because without that you lose
a sense of fairness a sense of justice
you get a sense from the people that you
spoke to how police could begin that
process right well the thing from
there's a story in my book about a young
man who was shot and he does something
really remarkable in the city which is
he identifies the shooter and agrees to
testify and then he faces threats over
the course of the next year and then on
a Saturday afternoon in a gentrified
park is shot in the back of the head and
killed him there were all these
witnesses and nobody is willing to come
forward and there's nothing to do with
this kind of mythical no snitch culture
but it has everything to do with this
sense of fear and part of that I think
results from the fact that we have a in
Chicago the police have a very low
closure rate so you've got a pretty a
one in four chance of getting away with
shooting and killing somebody right and
1/10 chance of shooting somebody and so
without that sense of justice I think
that Trust just erodes you write about
Farrow who I believe appeared in your
first that's right no children who
described his initially being seeming
unaffected by witnessing a murder right
but but later you see the truth right he
he takes a cab home one day from our
house he was living with us takes a cab
home to visit his mom and when he gets
there some two men
yank him out of the cab and getting the
cab and shoot and kill the cab driver
and an attempted robbery and fara
witnesses all this and so I 20 years
after the fact when I was working on
this book I sat down at a restaurant to
talk with him about it and he begins I
he it's like he's back in the moment in
fact he gets out of the booth and starts
crouching and I have to yank him back in
and it was clear that that that incident
had so gotten into his bones I've never
left him yeah and he by the way from
that book I was telling you and I read
it he stayed with us this book also will
see me with you Alex thank you so much
for the time well thanks for having me